[Musique]
l'actualité de ce mercredi 2 février
2022 marquée par l'ouverture de la cité
de l'emploi de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines dispositif piloté
par la préfecture qui permet de garantir
aux résidents des quartiers prioritaires
de la ville les mêmes opportunités
d'insertion le même accès à
l'information et le même accompagnement
qu'à l'ensemble de la population parmi
les autres faits du jour le sursis
accordé aux possesseurs de véhicules
critères 3 pour rouler en ile de france
ou encore la plainte classée sans suite
du professeur de philosophie didier
lemaire à trappes nous parlerons
également des sorties ciné avec des
acteurs et réalisateurs yvelinois à
l'honneur et en ce jour de chandler
notre invité aujourd'hui jason vers
l'europe il nous a ouvert les portes de
son restaurant à fontenay le fleury pour
nous apprendre à réaliser des crêpes
comme un chef
[Musique]
je me trouve au siège de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines basée à
trappes c'est ce mercredi à 2 février
qui est lancé officiellement le
programme cité de l'emploi de sky une
convention a été signée à 17h par les
officiels dont nadia ministre de la
ville et jean michel fourgous les
précisions du président de saint quentin
en yvelines est-ce que ça va simplifier
on écoute et on essayait de 2 il ya
beaucoup de couleurs de l'emploi alors
on a essayé d'intégrer tout le monde
bien sûr mais il faut vraiment voir ça
comme une opération de simplification
s'est pas non plus à qui vont régler le
problème des six millions et demi de
chômeurs et puis surtout ce qu'on veut
c'est que c'est que l'état communique
les vrais chiffres du chômage alors à
quoi va servir ce dispositif cité de
l'emploi concrètement et bien c'est
renforcer l'accès à l'emploi et à la
formation aux habitants des quartiers
politique est de la ville et de
l'agglomération il dispose d'un taux de
chômage plus élevé que la moyenne et
l'objectif c'est leur garantir les mêmes
opportunités de réinsertion que le reste
de la population on écoute le
responsable c'est vraiment de la
coordination de réseaux d'acteurs
économiques d'acteurs liées à l'emploi
pour faire en sorte que les publics
banques échappent parfois aussi à ces
dispositifs est qu on trouve
principalement dans les quartiers
prioritaires puissent
on bénéficier dans les meilleures
conditions un déploiement sur le
territoire piloté par la préfecture la
cité de l'emploi de saint quentin en
yvelines est accompagné à part le
ministère de la ville à hauteur de 200
mille euros sur deux ans
[Musique]
l'actualité de ce 2 février c'est
également l'enquète pour menaces visant
le professeur de philosophie didier
lemaire classée sans suite le parquet de
versailles abandonne les investigations
sur les attaques qu'auraient subies
l'enseignant attrape faute d'éléments
probants ce dernier nous a confié ne pas
être surpris les propos retenus pouvant
s'apparenter à des opinions le maire de
trappes qui s'était opposé aux
professeurs à poster de son côté un
billet sur son compte facebook ce
professeur de philosophie était donc bel
et bien un mythomane qui a inventé des
menaces fictives pour exister
médiatiquement
cet homme pathologiquement attirés par
les projecteurs médiatiques aura commis
beaucoup de dégâts et sali la réputation
d'une ville de ses habitants et en
particulier de ses élèves elle des
propos qui pourraient laisser place un
nouveau dépôt de plainte pour
diffamation
la zone à faible émission ne sera
élargie à l'intérieur de l'a86 en
ile-de-france qu'au début de l'année
prochaine l'entrée en vigueur de cette
mesure devait intervenir au 1er juillet
2022 mais la métropole du grand paris
attend toujours des engagements de la
part de l'état autorisé des contrôles et
des verbalisations automatique mais
aussi la possibilité pour la métropole
de débloquer des prêts à taux zéro pour
aider les foyers les plus modestes a
changé de véhicule les interdictions de
circulation semaine de 8h à 20h
concerneront les véhicules à creed r 3
opus à savoir notamment les voitures
essence immatriculés avant le 1er
janvier 2006 où les diesels datant
d'avant le 1er janvier 2011
plus que jamais la branche des services
de l'automobile les organismes de
formation et les entreprises recrutent
donc il ya des opportunités et on
encourage vraiment les jeunes et les
salariés en reconversion professionnelle
et les demandeurs d'emploi à venir dans
nos formations parce qu'il ya vraiment
des opportunités d'embauché à l'issue le
message a été martelé lors des dernières
journées portes ouvertes du campus des
services de l'automobile et de la
mobilité à guyancourt la filière recrute
à l'an dernier les services de
l'automobile regroupait plus de 500
mille professionnels exerçant plus d'une
centaine de métiers au sein de 150 mille
entreprises cinq organismes vous
attendent ici pour vous former autour
des métiers de la voiture de moto et du
vélo que vous soyez en formation
initiale formation continue ou en
reconversion du bts au master en passant
par le bac pro les possibilités sont
nombreuses l'inscription se fait
notamment pour les étudiants sur
parcours sup la plateforme qui a ouvert
ses portes le 20 janvier triel-sur-seine
s'apprêtait à célébrer pour la première
fois le nouvel an chinois le 5 février
des animations des déambulations auront
lieu dans les rues pour le moment les
répétitions se poursuivre ce que vous
voyez derrière moi ce sens les
répétitions du nouvel an chinois puisque
à triel sur seine
ils nous ont rappelés en tant qu'école
de kung fu pour organiser pour faire les
festivités du nouvel an chinois pourquoi
une école de compos en fait que vous
voyez derrière moi ce sont toujours des
exploits techniques physiques
c'est extrêmement fatigant et donc les
villes prenait toujours l'école de kung
fu locale
voir animer le dragon animer les lions
animer les armes et à triel samedi
prochain vous allez voir tout ça réuni à
la fois dans les rues de la ville avec
bien sûr les percussions les pétards
parce qu'il faut faire beaucoup de bruit
donc ça c'est du mauvais esprit des
mauvais esprits depuis quelques temps il
y en a donc on va chasser tous les
mauvais esprits un esprit festif rendez
vous à partir de 16 heures dans les rues
commerçantes un village des saveurs sera
aussi proposée ça c'est un petit coup de
pouce du destin
batman c'est moi
ce 2 février sortie en salles de super
héros malgré lui l'illinois philippe
lachaux et sa bande à nouveau sur grand
écran pour une parodie des films marvel
et dc comics comédie et action pour cet
hommage aux principales franchises
américaines que la troupe est venu
présenter dans les yvelines récemment
vient du ce sont 18 on a passé nos parmi
nos meilleures années dans le 78 avec
une fille et du coup forcément quand on
revient ici qu'on présente le film dans
les yvelines on est hyper content ça
nous touche et puis ça nous fait quelque
chose donc c'est important pour nous
nouria de la celle saint cloud donc nous
les cinémas à l'époque c'était cinéma de
parler d'eux on y aller tout le temps
voilà on y avait en bande et tout donc
ouais retour aux sources on adore aussi
sont originaires des yvelines de
montfort l'amaury et grégoire ludig et
david marsais les deux comédiens du
palmashow sont de retour avec leur
nouveau film les vedettes sortie prévue
le 9 février avant première ce 5 février
à 20h30 à l'ugc à montigny le bretonneux
la rencontre de daniel chanteur raté et
endettée et de stéphane vendeur
d'électroménager plutôt doué au jeu
télévisé
[Applaudissements]
j'ai passé dans la vie conscience mais
vous avez un énorme potentiel
six films plus j'en ai conscience
resterai
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est jour de la chandeleur
et pour l'occasion je me trouve à la
crêperie de fontenay-le-fleury avec
jason son directeur bonjour bonjour mon
fils alors on va essayer de découvrir un
peu question des coulisses de la
préparation d'une crêpe donc pour
commencer est ce que vous pouvez me dire
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait des crêpes ce
jour là c'est le jour de la shoah
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait des crêpes
alors la chandeleur c'est pour fêter le
début de le début de la fin de l'hiver
on va dire ça comme ça voilà pour
représenter le soleil par rapport à une
crêpe qui est doré et voilà doré est
ronde reuters vous avez des crêpes qui
son indémodable classique dans votre
carte mais souvent vous imaginez des
nouvelles crêpes il ya des crêpes du
moment même
comment est ce que vous imaginez tout ça
comment est ce que vous pensez les
recettes apport alors pour les crêpes
les recettes on les a on les a piqués un
peu partout on va dire ça comme ça vous
allez encore tous là comme les crêpes au
sucre les crêpes au caramel au beurre
salé chez nous qui est fait maison
d'ailleurs vraiment toutes ces crapules
ans après on est parti un peu plus loin
dans l'expertisé on a fait des crêpes
avec de la noix de coco on rajoute des
boules de glaces artisanales dessus
vraiment si des crêpes et nord on va
dire ça comme ça vraiment c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment pas mal voilà
pour faire une nouvelle clientèle un peu
plus jeune pour sortir un peu de tout de
ce que tu me connais
[Musique]
et tu vas venir nous voir comme ça
oracle est un peu et tu vas faire comme
ça tac tac tac et la retourner tu
commences à retour des coques seront
très abattu
comme ça sur moi
là tu vas retourner au spectacle
[Musique]
ok
vous avez d un ingrédient secret dans la
préparation de votre crêpe parce que
vous le dire
mais oui oui on en a alors nous
personnellement nous ne mettons pas de
nom mais également notre farine et bio
importé directement de bretagne c'est
très important pour nous et voilà et le
petit secret qu'on aura ce serait
remettre un peu de miel de fleurs voir
rapporter un peu sucré salé dans la
galette d'accord et du conte sont bons
mais du rhum ou de la bière dans la
préparation d'une crêpe on dit que ça la
rendent meilleure est ce que vous c'est
ce que vous faites tout ce que au
contraire bah vous ne faites pas du tout
fin qu'est ce que vous en pensez moi je
pense qu'il n'a pas besoin sur l'a2
recette de base sa dépense ça dépend
vraiment des goûts à la maison peut être
un peu de bière ou juin et voilà c'est
pas obligatoire c'est rarement pour
ajouter un peu de boue nous on sucre
notre pâte à crêpes par contre on met du
sucre ça c'est un grand débat aussi à
ceux conçus krupa la pâte à claques on
le sait personnellement est-ce que vous
pouvez donner des conseils à nos
téléspectateurs qui voudrait réaliser
eux mêmes leur propre crème chez eux est
ce qu'il ya des conseils à voir des
gestes pour avoir vraiment une crêpe
super bonne est parfaite il n'y a pas de
secret il faut bien faire reposer la
pâte et voilà et avant le petit coup de
main qui va avec aussi parce que ça
c'est important les petits coups de main
le retourner très vite et ça exactement
soit vous avez une crêpière ou bilik ça
dépend de comment elle appelle et vous
avez le petit coup de main en rond soit
vous avez une poêle directement et vous
la faites tourner et vous la retourne et
merci beaucoup de jeunes pour tous ces
conseils maintenant vous en saurez un
peu plus j'espère sur la chandeleur mais
également sur comment préparer de bonnes
fêtes
[Musique]
nous refermons ce journal avec
l'information qu'il faudra suivre dans
les prochains jours la publication des
parrainages obtenus par les candidats à
la présidentielle une première liste
vient d'être dévoilée par le conseil
constitutionnel
rappelons que 500 parrainages d'élus
sont nécessaires pour pouvoir se
présenter au scrutin à ce jour seuls
deux signatures d'élus du département
ont été validés celle de richard
delpierre maire du chesnay rocancourt en
faveur d' emmanuel macron et celle de
jean michel fourgous maire d'elancourt
en faveur de valérie pécresse la liste
sera actualisée chaque mardi chaque
mercredi jusqu'au 4 mars 18h
[Musique]